what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can help decide what direction
the content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable
future okay so with Spider-Man
Homecoming coming out this week I
thought it'd be a good time to have this
discussion sort of offer this
explanation on the Spider-Man film
rights because I think it's one thing
that really throws a lot of people off
and there's a lot of Articles out there
that talk about it and things like that
but they can be kind of confusing and so
we're going to simplify this whole thing
so right now with Spider-Man homecoming
the first thing to clarify is that
Marvel does not own the film rights to
Spider-Man they're borrowing him and
here's the reason why so this all goes
back to like the 1990s right the comic
bus to the 1990s we've talked about the
comic bus we don't have to go into this
great big huge grandiose explanation I
liking the comic bus of the 1990s to
like a red diamond right like let's say
you're walking down the road and you
find a red diamond all right it's never
been seen before and people are just
like wow man this is a red diamond it's
worth a ton of money millions and
millions and millions and millions of
dollars but then some guys hiking
through to a cave and he finds a wall
full of red diamonds well suddenly yours
is with a whole lot less and so comic
books were basically the exact same way
the idea is that once the average person
began to realize that comic books could
be worth a lot of money depending on
what the story was people started buying
them in droves The Death of Superman for
example it's the story where Superman
died people were just like oh man this
is going to be worth a whole lot of
money I'm going to go ahead and buy it
the death of Jean Gray the first
appearance of The Flash Barry Allen so
on and so forth the issue with this is
that Marvel and DC all they saw was that
people were buying a whole bunch of
comics and so they just started printing
more of those same Comics well this ran
into the same scenario as the wall full
of diamonds the more comics that were
out there the less valuable Comics
became and so because of that people
were who were going out and buying them
and saying man I can put my kid through
college in like 20 years they just
stopped buying Comics because Comics
weren't worth as much anymore well the
issue with this is that DC Comics was
owned by Warner Brothers so they weren't
going anywhere they had corporate
backing Marvel Comics was not owned by
anybody they had no Financial backing
and so if Marvel Comics couldn't sell
comics books then they were going to go
under one day you would turn on the news
and they would just say and Marvel
Comics has gone bankrupt and they're
just kind of being you know sold off
peac
Meal which kind of begs the question
what would have happened if that had
actually taken place and like Warner
Brothers had bought Marvel Comics and
you had Warner Brothers that owned
Marvel and DC Comics you definitely see
DC Comics and Marvel Comics crossing
over a whole lot more but that's neither
here nor there with regards to our
discussion on Spider-Man in a last ditch
effort to basically stay afloat to keep
from going under financially and having
to close its doors Marvel began selling
off the licensing rights to its
characters now this does not mean that
Marvel sold off the rights to its
characters and it may seem like there's
no difference there but the difference
is huge licensing rights means the
licensing in film form which means that
the characters as they appear in films
if Marvel had sold off the rights to
Spider-Man then it would have meant that
Marvel couldn't publish Spider-Man as a
comic book anymore admit that Marvel
wouldn't be able to make money on
Spider-Man merchandise so like toys and
clothes and different things like that
that's what it would mean if they sold
off off the rights when they sold off
the licensing rights that simply means
that in terms of Spider-Man appearing in
film form Marvel does not own that
aspect of him instead Marvel had sold
off the licensing rights for Spider-Man
to Sony now Marvel also sold the
licensing rights for the X-Men and the
Fantastic 4 respectively to Fox and I
believe they sold off the licensing
rights to the Incredible Hulk to
Universal and I think Neymar the
Submariner to Universal that's the
reason why you haven't seen an
Incredible Hulk film recently because
there's some kind of distribution issue
I think between uh Marvel studios in
Universal with regards to the Incredible
Hulk Neymar's back at Marvel Now Blade's
back at Marvel Now different things like
that but again you know a lot of that
stuff still kind of wishy-washy and
isn't really clear except for those who
were in The know which I'm not one of
those people because I don't work in
Hollywood but the fact remains here that
for the Spider-Man character really
after the success of the original X-Men
film by Fox in 2000 Sony decided to
launch their own Spider-Man property
under Sam Rey and Spider-Man 1 was
really good it was pretty enjoyable
Spider-Man 2 was pretty good too
Spider-Man 3 was not very good at all
and so the result was that with Marvel
Studios under Kevin feige picking up
steam in the mid 2000s with Iron Man 1
it led to Sony trying to reinvigorate
their Spider-Man franchise and try to
catch on to the growing trend of comic
book movies because with Marvel Studios
not having the X-Men not having the
Fantastic 4 and not having Spider-Man
they kind of had to scrape the bottom of
the barrel so to speak and then make the
best with what they had they literally
had to make dinner on a dollar and so
because of that they were able to crank
out some pretty cool stuff I mean given
the characters that they had it's pretty
interesting which really begs the
question what would the Marvel Cinematic
Universe look like if Marvel had the
licensing rights to the Fantastic 4 in
the X-Men it probably would have been a
lot more grandiose than it currently is
right now and the weight of Civil War
would have been a lot bigger than it was
in the movies and infinity War would be
absolutely insane I mean imagine that
like aund some odd characters you know
the X-Men the Fantastic 4 all those
characters you know just kind of trying
to fight against Thanos with The
Infinity Gauntlet it'd be pretty Bonkers
but in any event we're kind of we're
kind of digressing here I have a really
bad tendency to do that to sort of go
off on these little tangents so jumping
back into into our main discussion here
with regards to Spider-Man because of
the fact that Sony had gone back to the
drawing board and they had launched
Amazing Spider-Man 1 and Amazing
Spider-Man 2 with Andrew Garfield
neither of those movies had done
anywhere near as well as Sony had
expected they did pretty well
financially but you have to remember the
Sony Pictures arm of Sony has been
struggling financially for quite some
time I mean the Emoji movie that's
coming out later on this year is like do
or die if the Emoji Movie doesn't work
the rumor is that Sony's going to give
serious thought to eliminating Sony
picture in its entirety and selling it
off don't take that as absolute truth
that's just what the rumor Mills
cranking out so that's kind of what I've
heard but the fact remains here that
with Amy Pascal being the head of Sony
pictures in 2015 I think it was maybe
2014 she had gone to Kevin feige who's
the head of Marvel Studios under Disney
and it said look we can work out an
arrangement for you guys to be able to
use Spider-Man and so what ended up
happening here is a deal was brokered
between between Sony and uh and Marvel
Studios under Disney what this deal
basically entailed is is that Sony
Pictures would be the ones who would
basically pay for the film's creation
and distribute the film Marvel Studios
would be the ones who decide like the
director who would decide the cast who
would decide like the screenplay the
tone of the story all that kind of good
stuff so they would basically be the
creative end of the project now because
of the fact that Sony's the One
financing the film because of the fact
that Sony's the one that's going to be
Distributing the film Sony's the company
that's going to be making the money at
the box office but with Marvel you know
while Marvel Studios doesn't really make
any money off the film per se it does
give them the ability to include
Spider-Man in Spider-Man homecoming to
have included Spider-Man in Civil War to
include Spider-Man in The Avengers
Infinity Wars and then include
Spider-Man in Spider-Man homecoming 2
which I imagine is probably going to
result in him dying and is going to
introduce Miles Morales I have no idea
where we go with Spider-Man after
homecoming 2 I have no no clue and
that's anybody's guess at this point to
be honest because that's so far ahead
that I don't think anybody's really had
a chance to think that far along the
lines but the fact remains here that
this does benefit while does seem like a
very one-sided deal it's actually not
and the reason why is because of the
fact that Spider-Man being in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe bolsters the
popularity of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so sure Marvel Studios is not
making any money off Spider-Man
homecoming they're not making any money
off the film I mean if that movie ends
up grossing a billion dollars at the box
office that all goes to Sony none of it
goes to Marvel at all none of it goes to
Disney but if it grosses a billion
dollars at the box office it means
everybody's going to go out and buy
Spider-Man toys it means everybody's
going to go out and buy Spider-Man
clothes is going to go out and buy
Spider-Man this and Spider-Man that
backpacks and all that kind of good
stuff kids are going to want all the
Spider-Man stuff which Marvel and Disney
will make money on that so they do
benefit on that end at the same time it
also drums up a lot of popularity and so
like Civil War for example was a Marvel
Cinematic Universe movie Marvel Studios
made money on that movie and so with
Spider-Man being in it they made a ton
of cash off of that with regards to
Spider-Man being in the Avengers
Infinity War films they make a ton of
money off of that again it bolsters up
you know a rising tide lifts All Ships
and so if Spider-Man homecoming does
well then that means that people are
going to go into Avengers Infinity War
even more excited for the appearance of
Spider-Man they're going to go into the
sequel or I guess the second movie
that's part of infinity War more excited
for Spider-Man and they're going to go
into Spider-Man homecoming 2 curious to
see what happens to his character and so
again it's going to continue to bolster
up the financial side of uh of Marvel
and Disney just because of the fact that
people are going to be interested in
seeing what happens next but that's
essentially what goes on with the rights
right now it's more of a Shar deal it's
this idea that in terms of any
Spider-Man related solo film so
Spider-Man homecoming 1 and Spider-Man
homecoming 2 Sony gets all the money for
that and the other Spider-Man
appearances so in Civil War and in The
Avengers uh infinity War Stories Marvel
Studios makes the money on that because
they're banking everything else that
goes on they don't need Spider-Man for
those movies it helps but it's not
required at all so again it's just kind
of a shared deal at this point and so
what seems to be happening or at least
what seems most likely to happen once
Spider-Man homecoming 2 comes out and
that movie is over it seems like
Spider-Man's going to revert back to
Sony and so it's really one of these
things where I guess all heads will turn
to Sony and people are like okay
Spider-Man's buil been built up in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now let's see
what you can do which if their track
recorders any indication they're just
going to screw it all up but I have no
idea so in any event guys we're going to
go ahead and bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
oh